welcome back to new rockstars I mean I'm
marina masters and the upcoming Joker
film starring Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur
flick the newest incarnation the Clown
Prince of Crime is looking to be the
darkest Joker we've seen yet that's
right
darker than damaged yep but does that
make this Joker the real Joker is there
such a thing right isn't the Joker's
origin story meant to be kind of a
mystery just speaking in questions make
this more of a Riddler video does it it
could well this new Joker movie is not
part of the previous Cinematic Universe
like other DC EU films we've seen like
Suicide Squad Batman V Superman it's
setting in the past so just a new
timeline for DC some are calling DC
black one that could revolve around the
cult of Joker that's right The Joker
verse that's right we're gonna break
down how this upcoming Joker film could
redefine the way DC movies are made how
it could set up movies like the Batman
in birds of prey and the totally tinfoil
way all the Joker's could be connected
totally 10 Phi I want to get totally
tinfoil tattoos in my head please do it
we're waiting in case you want this
joker takeover to hit you by surprise
and be sure to check out our recent
Joker discussion on the latest episode
of rogue theory the two of us joined
Phillip and Leo to prove how the Joker
will be the next Santa Claus okay
despite Joker 2019 being set outside of
the DC EU it is still set in the general
DC world with a number of Gotham and DC
Easter eggs and supporting roles by
Thomas Wayne Alfred Pennyworth in a
young Bruce Wayne who I guess missed the
GI Joe PSA about strangers finger in
your mouth so weird
this Joker story is more grounded in
realism flex suffers from mental illness
from pressures of being a struggling
comedian which we know nothing about
Joaquin Phoenix even said he based his
Joker laugh on the videos of people
suffering from pathological laughter a
real neurological disorder and in this
film
Joker's nihilism seems to inspire a
movement like a kind of class warfare
the privileged elite like Thomas Wayne
dismisses this movement so in a sense
Thomas Wayne creates this Joker and
perhaps that this Joker creates the
conditions for a new Batman to rise yeah
I don't think anyone needs to see little
Bruce watch his parents get more
again stop seeing movies in the bad part
of town Wayne's too many pearls have
been spilt and you guys are rich like go
to the Opera in the downtown area where
one that exists that's nice yeah we've
gotten like to Peter Parker's spider
bites and at least like four traumatised
little purses but maybe in this mid DC
timeline the fates of the Wayne's are
different director Todd Phillips has
straight-up declared his intention for
Joker to launch DC black saying that he
told the studio let Joker be the first
and then let's get F mean great
filmmakers to come in instead of trying
to live in the shadow of the Beast MCU
is what he's talking about let's do
something they can't he's saying like
thirty million dollar budgets no CGI
Phillips said let's strip all that away
it'll be liberating a DC film series
reimagined through the eyes of the Joker
what would this joke reverse look like
well the next film on DC's lineup after
the Joker is birds of prey coming in
February 2020 it's featuring Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn joining Black
Canary Huntress and Renee Montoya to
rescue Cassandra Cain from black mask
that Harley Quinn came from Suicide
Squad and the Jared Leto version of the
Joker
but if Joker 2019 does well I could see
DC rebranding birds-of-prey as another
DC black film starring another antihero
from Gotham's rogue gallery and speaking
of the rogues gallery all of the rumors
we've heard about the upcoming Matt
Reeves the Batman story Robert Pattinson
coming in June 2021
suggested the story might be set in
Arkham Asylum with Batman facing many of
his colorful demons we might even get
like an implication that this Bruce
Wayne is the tortured soul who grew up
from the kid Arthur Fleck stranger
endangered it's not cool right after the
Batman will be James Gunn's the Suicide
Squad which could also be set in this DC
black Joker verse essentially many of
DC's films going forward could be set in
a villain corrupted world separate from
the DC EU we've known and whatever this
new universe looks like it sounds like
the idea is to avoid the whole idea of a
shared Cinematic Universe with crossover
cameos and team ups what am i doing
directing traffic
so while walking Phoenix is playing the
Joker in this new film
I don't think Phillips is suggesting
that Fleck is the definitive Joker no
that's the idea behind this cult of
Joker theory we brought up earlier in
this new DC black timeline Arthur Fleck
may be one of many people to wear clown
makeup and plunge Gotham into anarchy
yeah like Joker 2019 Christopher Nolan's
The Dark Knight and even Tim Burton's
1989 Batman present Joker's who share
their clown iconography with other
deranged Minds in their group like they
thought that anyone can laugh all the
world burns a sadistic gangster a
maniacal show man a domestic terrorist
and inked out creep all torchbearers of
the same nihilistic cult or as Leo
pitched us a succession of Santa Claus
like figures who have to kill the
previous one to claim the title Leto
Joker kills Phoenix Joker Ledger Joker
kills Leto Joker and then Santa gives
presents to everybody yeah whatever this
one-inch it's just in with like animated
mark hamill Joker on the throne long may
he reign Leo's theory is it's my new
favorite by the way because if you think
about it he's basically saying whatever
Santa Claus that you meet is a murderer
it's the coat used to be white Oh
which Joker do you think it's a
definitive Joker and should DC films
move forward in a universe centered
around the Joker and the themes he
represents or should the holdovers from
the Justice League like Wonder Woman and
Aquaman carry this torch comment down
below with your thoughts and subscribe
to new rock stars for more hot takes on
the Joker and DC movies and Santa follow
me on Twitter and Instagram add me on
Twitter at Marina Mastro's I'm Erik
Bosse I'm marina Mastro thanks for
joining us in whichever in whatever
[Laughter]
right